Informatics for Integrating Biology and
the Bedside, or i2b2 for short,
is an NIH-funded effort based at
Partners HealthCare System in Boston.
Its mission is to enable clinical
investigators to conduct research
using state of the art genomics and
biomedical informatics.
As compared to hQuery,
it's a far more sophisticated system to
support complex research environments.
But it provides an easily
understood database schema
that can be used to create a data
warehouse, where clinical abstracts from
an enterprise EHR can be stored for
future analysis.
This is important because the database
scheme of commercial enterprise EHRs can
be dauntingly complex,
is usually proprietary, and
it is not necessarily designed
well to support ad hoc queries.
i2b2 implementations are comprised
of cells that communicate with each
other via web services and together,
are called a hive, as shown here.
And no, Marla,
it doesn't contain any honey.
The role of most of these cells or
web services should be
clear from their names.
Importantly, custom cells
can be added to the hive.
There's an organized i2b2 users
group to share information and
applications and to create the potential
for translational research
through collaboration in federated
queries across institutions.